they see morales sells food on the
streets of katya a working-class
neighborhood in caracas the ongoing
economic crisis on the lockdown are
having a big impact in her life we are
only working three hours a day i
understand they are doing it to protect
our health but I'm a single mother of
two children
and my eldest daughter and her son also
live at home I think the situation will
get worse every day
security forces on the streets are
trying to enforce a lockdown to prevent
the spread of kovat 19 but people are
becoming more and more desperate every
day on Thursday reports of looting and
clashes with security forces in several
states around the country show how dire
the situation is kovat 19 may generate
fear among people but surviving everyday
is the main worry for many government
figures show that venezuela has around
300 confirmed cases of kovat 19
president Nicolas Maduro says the
country has tested over 200,000 people
with the help of the Chinese government
that is the medium term goal we have to
reach a million tests at this stage
we've carried out 250,000 but we have to
reach 10 million tests to comply with
the complete protocol of the World
Health Organization there are two types
of testing being done
the PCR that tests the virus genetic
material and the rapid tests that are
less sensitive than the PCR that's why
doctors like Julio Castro say the virus
may be severely under diagnosed in
Venezuela limitation of the amount of
tests prevents you from doing lots of
them but it may be greatly underreported
what we think the government is doing is
mixing PCR tests and rapid tests you
cannot mix pairs with apples the numbers
reflect different things Venezuelan
hospitals are already struggling with
shortages of almost everything only 70%
of them have running water and so we
spoke to Oscar Navas a doctor in the
state of and Swahili he says he supports
the call by opposition leader Huang
Widow
to pay extra money to healthcare workers
that fight kovat 1980 like me get one
dollar fifty a month
and that's why my interim president one
guy doe will use some resources to give
$100 a month to those who qualify and
work in the health sector the money
comes from accounts that have been
recovered from the government and will
be paid as virtual money for three
months Venezuela's health care system is
already stressed to the limit the spread
of kovat 19 can easily make it collapse
terasawa
al-jazeera